you know it's important not to idealize
the past
the world during my childhood certainly
wasn't perfect the media we consumed at
the time wasn't perfect either
but one thing i do remember is that
children's shows
were broadly speaking shows for children
they had
childish themes and ideas and plots the
moral at the end of every story was
always something like
sharing is good or learning is fun
and this all made a lot of sense the
show blues clues was
a little bit after my time it debuted
when i was in middle school i think if i
remember correctly but my younger
siblings were
blues clues fanatics so i was exposed to
the show a fair amount
during a typical episode blue the
cartoon dog would decide that he wanted
to
you know make puppets out of
construction paper or something and then
he discovered that his scissors are
missing
and with the help of his human friend
steve and the children watching at home
blue would search around the house for
his scissors and then he would
eventually find the scissors
and that would be the end of the episode
suspense drama
sorrow redemption the show had it all or
at least it had enough
for the preschoolers in the audience
those preschoolers they don't need much
from their entertainment
innocent and simple should be the name
of the game and that's what many
children's shows used to be
that's what blue's clues used to be but
not anymore
like so many other forms of child
entertainment blue's clues went from
looking for his scissors to
[Music]
this family has two mummies they love
each other so proudly and they all go
marching in the big parade
families marching two by two hurrah
hurrah
families marching two by two hurrah
hurrah
this family has two daddies they love
each other so proudly and they all
go marching in the big
parade come on friends family's marching
three by three hurrah
hurrah families marching three by three
hurrah
hurrah these papas are non-binary they
love each other so proudly and they all
go marching in the big
parade
[Music]
yes a non-binary disabled dolphin
and i i also i hope you notice the uh
black lives matter fist on the
microphone so they really they really
jammed it all in there
yes that is a pride parade featured on a
recent episode of the show blues clues
a show which again is targeted
specifically at children aged three to
five
the person singing is a man named andrew
levitt who goes by
nina west when he's on stage as a drag
queen
and that's apparently not the first time
that blue's clues has delved into lgbt
propaganda they recently released a
video featuring young children talking
about the different pride flags and what
they mean
there are of course many pride flags to
signify many different sexual
proclivities
the parade segment we just watched goes
on for a while listing many of them
starting with gay and lesbian and then
as you saw
disabled non-binary dolphins and then
into trans and beyond
let's watch a little more just to see
how far
this actually goes families marching six
by six hurrah
hurrah families marching six by six
hurrah
hurrah a spy and pan grown ups you see
can love each other
so proudly and they all go marching
in the big parade oh yeah
ace bye and pan sound like the names of
you know members of a boy band or
something but uh no a spy and pam
because it's important that that
three-year-olds
be taught about pansexuals by the way if
you're wondering what ace means i had to
look that up
that's a term used for asexuals now if
you're wondering why asexuals that is
people who experience
no sexual attraction at all are included
in a community of people who identify
themselves
by their attraction to other people and
why anyone would be proud of not being
attracted to other humans anyway
well that i can't really explain all i
can say is that the lgbt umbrella has
become more like a mushroom
growing and growing until it has reached
now a point where it's defined
not by what it is but by what it isn't
the only similarity between an asexual
someone who isn't attracted to anybody
and a pansexual someone who's attracted
to everybody
is that neither are heterosexual the
point of pride for lgbt people these
days
seems to simply be that they aren't
straight
it's not a gay pride parade it's it's a
not
straight parade it's all about what you
aren't
it's not really about what you are this
is an important fact to keep in mind
especially as we enter
into what has now been deemed pride
month it used to be
you know you had a one part of a day the
pride parade and then it was pride day
and then
it was a week and now it's pride month
many corporation institutions
corporations and institutions will go
out of their way this month even more
than they do every other month to push
this agenda on to the public and
especially onto kids
kellogg's for example recently unveiled
a pride cereal
developed in association with the gay
activist group glad
the marketing campaign declares that
boxes are for serial
not people and on the side of the box
there's a list of pronouns with a couple
of blank spaces so that kids can fill in
their own pronouns if they want
ironically they say boxes are for serial
not people and then invite children to
literally put themselves into a box
indeed the lgbt movement is all about
boxes
it's all about obsessively identifying
and labeling people
the last thing they want is for children
to be free and unencumbered able to
explore the world
figure themselves out from a very young
age
they say to the kids here are the labels
now pick one for yourself and assume an
identity that coincides with it
of course they'll never be honest about
any of this
the fact the absolutely undeniable
indisputable fact which is staring us
right in the face
is that the cultural powers that be
really
desperately want your kid to be gay or
trans
or some variation thereof and they are
going to do what they can
to make that happen
but they won't admit it instead they'll
tell you that all of this
pride parades and pansexuals in schools
in shows for three-year-olds non-binary
pronouns on cereal boxes etc
all of this is about inviting kids to be
themselves they'll say
it's about inviting the three-year-olds
who are already
trans or gay or pansexual to simply come
out and live their authentic truth
now if you're still buying that line
then you may be a hopeless case
i don't know what to tell you i can't
force oblivious people to use their
brains if they've gotten so comfortable
living without them
but for everybody else the truth should
be clear by now
this of course has nothing to do with
inviting kids to be who they are
there are no transgender three-year-olds
or bisexual three-year-olds
or pansexual three-year-olds
three-year-olds are not concerned with
expressing their sexual identities
mostly because they don't have a sexual
identity at that age
they're concerned mostly with eating
snacks and running around without their
shoes on
and playing with their toys if we wanted
to help them live
their truth quote unquote that's the
truth we would help them live
this hyper sexualization this incense
incessant propagandizing
is rather about introducing a new quote
truth
it's about turning them into something
that they would not otherwise be
and as we already covered the identity
that our most powerful cultural
institutions
want a child to adopt is a negative
identity
the message to the child is simple in a
way it's simple
be what you want to be be who you want
to be
but don't be straight don't be quote
cisgender
don't adopt any values or worldviews or
ideas that your grandparents may have
held
so be whoever you want to be just not
that
here are your boxes there are a lot of
boxes
but you have to choose one and choose it
early
and find your identity and your purpose
in it
that's the message though the people
spreading that message
will never be honest about it well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the matt
wall show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button right down there
so you can stay up to date on all of our
future content